[Music]
you
hallo you two just Louis and my friends
this is guns in here
welcome to my 40th episode of chest
strap series today I'm going to show you
a very interesting line and in fact a
high profile trap in the CARICOM
exchange variation from the white
perspective the great thing about this
trap is chess legend and former world
champion Vishwanath Annan has once
fallen into this trap so if you prepare
well then you can definitely use this
line in the tournament practice the
opening arises after the falling water
ephone c6 d 4d far and now white
exchange in the center with he kept us
defy and see cactus d5
okay the mainline start with Bishop to
d3 so very important point
stopping black light squared bishop
development and accordingly black
continue with Knight to c6 not only
hitting the d4 pawn but if allowed then
Knight to b4 is the obvious choice
well white needs to stop it and
accordingly c3 is the best reply
finally we have reached to the critical
junction where black has two major
choices
number one Knight to f6 and number two
Queen to c7
in this episode we are going to
concentrate on one of the trendy move by
black namely Queen to c7 so idea is very
obvious black votes to stop White's
dark square bishop development here
white has many choices but I am going to
propose this very crafty Moon Knight g2e
to
so as you can see now Bishop to f4 is
definitely on the card and that's why
the mainline continue with Bishop to g4
so blacks idea is very obvious he wants
to take this bishop out before he closed
down the pawn chain finally note that
moves such as f3 doesn't create any
problem for the black cab as generally
black respond this move with Bishop to
d7 and then follow up with quickie Phi
which in fact give great position to the
black camp
so white needs to castle first and after
the obvious response a6 which liberate
the dark square bishop
here comes the very cunning and tricky
move Queen to even which sets up the
basic platform for our upcoming trap
so let's see what is wrong when black
try to develop the kingside piece and
obvious responses Bishop to d6 which is
attacking on the weak as to pawn
well if you have seen this position
first time you might think what has to
play either the MU H 3 and save his age
to pawn right well guess what
nope now the big idea reveals as white
will indeed continue with them f3
black has to move the bishop and
unfortunately it has the only square
Bishop to h5 however first thing first
you may ask well why can't black just
snap up the pawn first with Bishop
captures - you check right you are
winning a pawn and now I can move the
bishop
in fact yes he can except he is going to
lose a piece how let's check out first
option Bishop to a5 is a pretty bad one
has after Bishop catches f5
pawn captures f5 and now very simple
move Knight to g3 are discovered chat to
the black King and in the next turn we
are going to grab this loose bishop
so that radiation is completely out of
the equation you might think okay if
that's not possible then how about
Bishop to h5 saving everything right not
just one move and black and resign and I
hope you did see it right Queen to h5 ha
ha ha and one of the bishop is a Connor
so it is pretty clear that if black
continued with Bishop captures as true
then opening disaster is just waiting in
the corner so accordingly in the game
Vishy Anand continue with Bishop to h5
not falling for this Bishop captures
Ashe to trick however just one move
Queen to h4 and black is completely
paralyzed
the most surprising part about this trap
is when I checked the database there are
more than 16 AIIMS and GM's has fallen
into this trap so you can see the
potential of the slide
now the important point you need to know
over here that when black played the
move Bishop to g6 he get instantly bad
position after the following sequence
Bishop captures g6 and as the h1 is pin
Black has to take with their pawn and
suddenly you can see that not only black
has fractured his pawn structure but
this week a six backward pawn is a clear
target and once white can manage some
heavy pieces on the e-file then e six
pawn is doomed
to the death
so I think here white get huge
positional advantage
obviously Vishy Anand saw this coming so
he played the other choice namely Knight
to f6 which is defending on h5 and
trying to avoid this positional trap and
indeed his opponent doesn't respond
properly and he continued with Knight to
f4 which after few complications black
indeed managed to draw the game however
here white has a winning shot and before
I move on I like you to pause this video
and find out what is the killer mu which
white missed in this game
did you spot it let's see the star mu is
Bishop to g5 and after this no matter
how we were black wriggles he cannot
save the loss of material we have a
double threat Bishop captures f6 and
then Queen captures that fire so
accordingly black has the only response
namely Bishop to g6 but now the task is
very easy Bishop captures g 6f captures
g6 Bishop captures f6 and after G
captures f6 why it should go ahead and
grab this pawn which gives him a
clear-cut pawn advantage in the opening
and not only that but because what is
currently attacking to spot black
response is almost forced he has to play
King to d7 and after that indeed white
can play the move Queen to h4 and
because of the black shaky King an extra
pawn advantage with some careful play
you can definitely convert this into the
full point
last but not least there is a small trap
exists if black foolishly continued here
with Bishop captures a stool which looks
again very natural but after King to h1
again there is a double attack on the
table and the only moon to say both the
threat is King to d7
however this is the worst version as
after just one
F for and that poor Bishop is once again
hunted down in the corner
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this wonderful high profile trap
in the exchange care can remember when
you opponent respond with popular choice
such as Bishop to d6 then give him this
rude shock with f3 and it doesn't matter
however black plays in this position the
quick victory is awaiting for you over
the board
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and I
will meet you in my next episode very
soon bye and take care